this is truly bizarre video from a very strange
person.
The president of the United States, Donald
Trump appeared to sort of fake or mimic an
orgasm while impersonating Lisa Page during
a bizarre rally in Minnesota.
This actually happened a couple of weeks ago,
but the video is now getting a lot more attention
because Lisa Page herself has commented on
it.
Lisa Page is a former FBI lawyer.
She is now speaking out.
She did a big interview with the daily beast
and is being widely quoted.
She left the FBI in 2018 Trump went after
her after her very hard.
She had an affair with an FBI agent named
Peter struck and Trump always talks about
struck and his lover Lisa Page, so on and
so forth.
Again, Lisa Page left the FBI in 2018 may
of 2018 struck was ultimately fired in August
of 2018 and Trump at a rally in Minnesota.
Read text messages between them from two years
prior and at one point Trump pretends to sort
of have an orgasm as page which Lisa Page
now says was a demeaning fake orgasm.
Can you imagine that this is where politics
are in 2019 and that Trump mimicking the orgasm
was the straw that broke the camel's back.
Check out this strange video.
It is disturbing.
I won't lie.
Also, SPI pay special attention to the crowd's
reaction to all of this.
That was 19 minutes after the oath of office
months earlier.
Peter struck where he and his lover Lisa Page
water group.
She's going to win 10 million to one.
She's going to win.
I'm telling you, Peter, I'm telling you, Peter,
she's going to win.
Peter.
Oh, I love you so much.
[inaudible]
love you Peter.
I love you too, Lisa.
At least.
Hello, Lisa.
Lisa.
Oh God.
I love you Lisa.
And if she doesn't win, Lisa, we've got an
insurance policy.
Lisa, we'll get that son of a bitch out.
We got an insurance card and we're living
through the insurance policy.
That's what it is.
The phony Russia hoax.
So there it is.
That's a strange one.
Some presidents attack their opponents character.
Others focus on Polish, uh, policy.
Uh, some presidents focus on domestic issues,
others on international.
I'm not aware of any other presidents ridiculing
intelligence agency lawyers by mimicking fake
orgasms.
It seems new to me.
And that aside, a president is attacking and
demeaning federal employees, public servants
like Lisa Page.
That alone is disgusting and it's an embarrassment
to the office of the presidency.
But the fake orgasm is just too much.
And even beyond that, you know, we expect
this from Trump now, but the crowd cheering
is really sick to us.
It's shocking, but this is sadly a bigger
portion of American society than we probably
want to admit.
This is one of those things that I think many
of us thought we would probably never see
the president reenacting sex in a rally in
front of a crowd of his fans, particularly
another us citizen who works for the government.
It's a sick, sick man, but our society is
sick because a room full of people cheered.
Yesterday I played for you a video of that
Trump supporter in Florida saying he supports
Trump because of family values.
Right?
Well, this is what he's supporting.
And at some point in the future, there will
be a documentary of this clip included in
some kind of retrospective of, uh, of the
United States of America under Trump, right?
And it will be part of our history.
One more time for that key moment from the
video.
I love you, Peter.
I love you too, Lisa.
At least.
Hello, Lisa.
Lisa.
Oh God.
I love you Lisa.
Now in his defense, I'm sure Trump has plenty
of experience being in rooms where there are
fake orgasms, but a rally with a few thousand
people just doesn't seem like the rice right
place for this.
Things have gotten really, really weird.
And I, my biggest fear about all of this,
as I've said before, is the degree to which
this type of thing has become normalized and
it has, even if we don't believe that it has
for us, for myself, I notice the normalization
happening.
I notice how I react much less strongly to
things that four years ago would have been
unthinkable to come out of the white house
or out of a president.
We're all fighting the normalization, and
the fear is that it will become so normalized
that this guy gets himself reelected in 2020.